Alright, lets see how you did and fill out the
concept map together. Lets start here in the center, personal
genetics. The decision to know is personal. And you must
provide consent. We talk more about the idea of consent and
the social implications of personal genetic information in lesson 12.
Now if we want to learn more about our personal genetics. The
23andMe process starts with a DNA sample obtained from our
saliva. And we can learn more about DNA, we learned about
the basics in Lesson 2. Now, the DNA sample and saliva is sent to the lab for
DNA extraction. And then there's a step of
DNA amplification. After amplification the sample will be hybridized
on a chip and the important part is
this is not sequencing, right, we learn that this
is not sequencing he genome. We're actually screening for
1 million different SNV's or Single Nuclear type Variance.
And they're named individually by their rsID
and together all these SNV's can represent
different alleles. And we learn more about
alleles, in lesson 6 in particular. But,
once we have this information then were
ready for Data Assembly and Analysis. Our
results will include information about traits, and
ancestry. We talked at length about traits
in lesson one, and a bit more in lesson five. The
types of traits we can learn about include monogenic traits, which
we'll learn more about in lesson eight, complex traits, which we'll
learn more about in lesson nine, and even particular traits that
have to do with interactions with drugs. Which we'll learn more
about in lesson 10. Now the information we learn about our
ancestry tracks our maternal line, our paternal line and even family
relationships which we'll learn a bit more about in lesson 11.
And we actually use a calculation called IBD,
or Identity By Descent, to determine some of
these family relationships. Together, combining information about our
ancestry and traits, we get a look at our
family traits. Which track individual genes. Shared by
various relatives. And we learned a lot about genes
in lessons three and four. I hope you
have a new appreciation for how all the information
we learned about so far is connected. And how it connects
into the information that we're going to learn in the remaining lessons.